if there's one thing that sets mark
ruffalo apart from Bruce Banner its his
propensity for spoilers dude means well
but in his enthusiasm for the MCU he
tends to give the game away and we're
not talking about a 1 or 2 time thing
it's a bona fide pattern let's start
with the undisputable king of this list
the time mark ruffalo spoiled the
shocking ending of Avengers infinity war
we're not talking about something so
minor as a Red Skull comes back or even
hey guys Thor crafts a new hammer in an
awesome space forage run by Game of
Thrones Peter Dinklage no Ruffalo did
not spoil by halves he gave away the
astonishing fact of Thanos his slaughter
of half of all life in the universe he
let loose in fact the spoiler equivalent
of the infamous snap itself it happened
during a Good Morning America interview
alongside Don Cheadle at first he merely
approached the spoiler teasing when
asked if Thor and the Hulk save Asgard
and thor ragnarok that let me just say
this like every other Marvel movie it
doesn't end well for the superheroes he
could have stopped there and still done
damage but instead he followed it up
with an absolute firecracker of a
sentence wait till you see this next one
everybody - Ruffalo went on to ask for a
rewind but the internet never forgets
every other moment on this list happened
within the context of an interview and
came from Ruffalo's own lips it's the
easiest way to spoil something after all
you talk to someone you're excited to
promote your work the whole world is
waiting to see what happens next
sometimes you say more than you should
the stakes are higher when you play one
of the most iconic characters of an
already legendary film franchise of
course but the general principle remains
from war to friendships loose talk is so
dangerous because it's so easy that's
what makes this spoiler so remarkable it
wasn't a slip of the tongue but a slip
of technology
in October 2017 Ruffalo turned on
instagrams livestream function during
the four ragnerok premiere to include
fans in the real-time excitement what a
cool way to appreciate those fans so
committed to the franchise that they
tune in for premieres right
unfortunately he then put his phone in
his pocket and forgot to close the app
ultimately streaming the audio of a good
portion of the movies early scenes
[Music]
happily ragnarok spectacular visuals
still enticed anyone who might have
caught the broadcast to come see the
real thing but it still remains one heck
of a blunder let's be real though
haven't we all left an app or two
running before this is one spoiler
that's hard not to forgive the entire
world held its breath as Avengers in
game approached billboards heralded its
arrival in every major city everyone has
a friend or two who spent the previous
month revisiting the decade spanning
slate of Marvel movies fans congregated
online to discuss the odds of phalluses
defeat the return of beloved characters
and whether or not cap would finally
call The Avengers to assemble as it
racked up millions by the second during
its stay in theaters one thing was made
very clear every single thing that
happens in in game matters to someone
there's no such thing as a small spoiler
within the context of this kind of
culture defining phenomenon so Ruffalo
revealing the end point of a long
developed relationship at the core of
the series is kind of a big deal on
April 8th Ruffalo jokingly referred to
the fact that he shot multiple different
endings to avoid being able to spoil any
one aspect of the film during an
interview with E news but he didn't stop
there he proceeded to point to Chris
Evans and say as we all know now though
Ruffalo apparently did not at the time
that is in fact caps ultimate fate in
the final scene of the film
Evans put it best in his response to
this bombshell like a bodily function
compared to those weapons-grade spoilers
this one is rather tame or rather it
would be if the MCU weren't the most
emotionally loaded financially huge and
imagination consuming game
luckily this little moment of
indiscretion ended up obscured by time
in the split nature of the final to
Thanos centric movies in October 2017
Ruffalo mentioned filming scenes with
rocket racoon in an interview with USA
Today he said it's a very funny
relationship that the two of them have
first of all it's the biggest superhero
in the smallest just keeping them in a
frame together as a feat and hilarious
in itself true but after infinity war
dawn did no scenes between the Hulk and
rocket took place this detail became a
spoiler suddenly we knew that hunk and
rocket were going to team up in an
effort to take fan OHS down and moreover
that banner would be able to access the
dormant giant within himself anew after
struggling to do so during infinity war
a retroactive spoiler but a spoiler
regardless okay so this next one isn't
really a spoiler
it's just silly dudes doing silly things
Ruffalo's let the Fleur Kim out of the
bag so many times now that one can only
guess at the seriousness of the tongue
lashings he's probably gotten at
Marvel's hands one moment however just
might have been coordinated by the
studio itself as a way to poke fun at
Ruffalo's affinity for spoilage Ruffalo
appeared on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon in October 2018 where he and
Fallon drift on his well-established
nature as a blabbermouth
I've been sort of put under surveillance
by by far Marvel yeah that's what you
talk though the segment up is containing
a major spoiler on Twitter and after it
aired directors Joe and Anthony Russo
jokingly told Ruffalo he was fired so
what was the big reveal well it wasn't
really a reveal at all actually Ruffalo
seemed to utter the title but The
Tonight Show bleeped it out to the
chagrin of fans everywhere the title of
the next Avengers movie is
online sleuths set to decoding the audio
and trying to lip-read but the results
were inconclusive until Marvel formally
announced it to be Avengers in game so
was it a real slip of the tongue now
this one seemed a bit too self-aware but
now that Ruffalo knows how firmly MCU
super fans hang on to his every word
maybe he'll chill out with the spoilers
from here on out but probably not check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]